ideas are
everything we're nothing without an idea
so i go where the ideas lead
when we get an idea that we love
you see it and feel it and know it all
at once
a desire for an idea is like putting a
little piece of bait
on the hook and lowering it into the
water
you don't know when they're going to
come or what will trigger them
lo and behold on a lucky day bingo
you'll catch an idea
and party time
if you want to make a feature length
film
all you need to do is get 70
ideas and you write these scenes on
three by five cards
and when you have 70 of them you've got
a feature film
find your own voice never give up
final cut and total creative freedom
everything is connected in some way or
another
you could be working on a painting
and suddenly something in that
gives you an idea for a film music
painting cinema this is the art life
in cinema i don't like rules
in low on drive we only had one shot
left to get
how did you get it by breaking the rules
my name is david lynch and this is my
master class
[Music]
you